SPEAKER: So, yeah I was
going to talk about test,
but I decided that that
was kind of boring.
I'm happy to talk your ear
off about it in person.
But I think a better
lightning talk
would be the work
that I've been doing
on Pub's versions solver, which
I think is really, really cool.
So I don't know how many of
you have used Pub before.
It Dart's package manager.
Way back in the day, Bob and
I worked on a version solver
for it, which is the
chunk of code that
takes your set of dependencies
declared in your Pub spec
and looks up all
of those packages,
looks up all of
their dependencies,
and figures out a
group of packages
that satisfies every dependency
in every transitive package,
while also ensuring that all of
the root packages' dependencies
are satisfied.
It turns out that this
is a really hard problem.
Those of you familiar
with complexity theory
might know it as MP hard.
Those of you who are not, trust
me it's really, really hard.
We got a pretty decent
solution working
that's sort of based on what a
lot of other package managers
do.
But one problem that many of
you have probably run into
is that the errors it
reports are not very good.
Kevin brought this up
in his talk earlier.
So my new algorithm is
designed to solve that.
And I think it does it
in a pretty clever way.
So instead of sort
of thinking about it
as just a list of
package versions to try
and thinking about hopping back
to old versions that failed
and trying different
versions of those
and trying different versions of
all the other packages in case
that changed something,
the way it works now,
is it thinks about it in
terms of facts about the world
that it knows are true.
So these are facts like, if
you depend on package foo,
then you must also
depend on this version
range of package bar.
Or facts like
package [? kwuks ?]
is incompatible
with package quack.
So you can take these facts
about the world, which
you can start off by
generating from the Pub spec,
and use a pretty
straightforward process
of taking decisions
you've already
made about which
packages to select,
figuring out which packages
are forced by that.
Like, if you have
package foo selected,
that means that you definitely
need at least this range
of package bar.
Eventually, you might
run into a conflict,
because sometimes you're
making decisions arbitrarily
based on which package
ranges are unsatisfied.
The really clever thing
about this new algorithm
is when it encounters
a conflict,
it doesn't just go back to
where the conflict happened
and make a different decision.
It actually looks
at the facts that
caused this conflict
to happen and combines
them using sophisticated
logic programming to come up
with a new fact
about the world that
is sort of heuristically
representing the root
cause of that conflict.
So for example, if you
have package foo that
depends on package bar
and package bar depends
on package baz, and package baz
doesn't match your current SDK
constraints, it will actually
be able to figure out, well, OK,
package baz can't be selected.
The reason we selected
package baz was because bar
depended on it.
So bar can't be selected.
The reason we have selected bar
was because foo depended on it.
So foo can't be selected.
And then it'll remember that
this range of versions of foo
can't be selected
ever, and it won't ever
try to select them again.
The really cool
thing about this,
in addition to just making
the version solving faster,
is it takes these
facts, and if it
runs into a conflict that can't
be solved, where there are
no more versions of packages
left to try, it can actually
figure out, OK, why did this
fact that says there are
no possible versions
that could ever
solve this package [? graph, ?]
why was this fact generated?
What two previous
facts did we combine,
using sophisticated
logic programming,
to create this new fact?
Why did those facts exist?
And eventually it'll get
back to the dependencies that
are declared in your Pub spec.
And it will be able to report
that to you as just plain text
and say, these are
exactly the reasons
why we couldn't find anything.
So I'm hoping to release this
in Pub sometime this quarter.
So keep an eye out.
[APPLAUSE]